des conjugale isation de la hache
l'allocation adulte handicapé très
concrètement et bien cette allocation ne
sera plus versée en fonction des revenus
du ménage ça offre une indépendance
financière aux personnes handicapées
vous ça a été voté quasiment à
l'unanimité il ya une seule voix contre
vous salué ce vote de l'assemblée
nationale je veux bien sûr que je le
salue c'est évident je dire c'était un
combat des écologistes on a déposé des
textes on a suivi sa et et notamment ici
ici au sénat c'est à l'e3 en quatre ans
de lutte pour arriver à sa position je
regrette
c'est pour moi derrière ce texte toute
la la je dire la démarche des manuels
macron qui ne fonctionne pas c'est à
dire que je dirais quasi tous les autres
tous les groupes politiques lui ont dit
non il ne on ne peut pas il faut des
conjuguer alizés il faut absolument
écouter
ce ce qu'on vous comme on dit ben voilà
on perd trois ans quatre ans pour un
texte qui va être adoptée qui sera en
application que en 2023
de ces gens qui attendent ça des
personnes qui ne se marient pas ou au
contraire qu'il faut les y obliger
divorcer pour pouvoir toucher leurs
indemnités
il va falloir qu'ils attendent encore
2023 alors qu'on aurait pu se régler ce
problème à plusieurs reprises puisque ce
texte est passé à plusieurs reprises au
sénat et l'assemblée nationale qu'est ce
que vous dites sur ce délai il reste une
minute mais ce délai de 2023 vous pensez
qu'il est légitime quand même une raison
n'est pas légitime encore une fois je
dis on aurait pu aller compliquée il est
compliqué parce qu'on a attendu les
n'empêche qu'on aurait pu le faire tout
de suite on aurait pu le faire l'année
dernière on aurait pu faire l'année
d'avant et donc encore une fois c'est
une responsabilité de la politique d'
emmanuel macron qui n'a pas vu les
choses et surtout qui n'a encore une
fois pas écouter le parlement donc je
pense qu'à un moment donné il va falloir
qu'ils entendent ça vous appeler le
gouvernement à mettre cette réforme en
place avant 2023 évidemment je pense que
tout le monde attend ça un jeu dont on
peut pas attendre éternellement voilà là
ça a été voté tout le monde maintenant
est d'accord vous l'avez dit à
l'unanimité pour dire que c'est une
bonne mesure il faut des conjugue alizés
donc mettons le en place tout de suite
merci guillaume motards et en sueur à
l'exo
[Musique]